الجمعيه العامه توافق باغلبيه ساحقه على
ادانه روسيا القرار تبنته نحو 60 دوله
واقرته باغلبيه 141 دوله ضد سبع دول فقط
مع امتناع 32 دوله عن التصويت
القرار اكد ان مبادئ ميثاق الامم المتحده
هي من تضمن السلام الشامل والعادل والدائم
في اوكرانيا
اكد القرار ايضا على الالتزام بالسياده
واستقلال ووحده اراضي اوكرانيا ضمن حدود
دوليه معترف بها
القرار طلب بالانسحاب الفوري والكامل وغير
المشروط للقوات الروسيه من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه
شمل القرار ايضا اسرى الحرب من الطرفين
الروسي والاوكراني وطلب بمعاملتهم وفقا
لمعاهدات جناز لعام
القرار شدد على ضروره واهميه محاسبه
المسؤولين عن اشد الجرائم خطوره وفقا
للقانون الدولي
عن نتيجه التصويت والرساله واضحه لا يهم
تفعله روسيا من محاولات لتقويض النظام
الدولي والتحالف الداعم لوحده اراضي
اوكرانيا لكنها تفشل مره تلو الاخرى
التحالف موجود وسيبقى طالما كانت هناك
رغبه في ان تنتصر اوكرانيا في جهودها ليس
للدفاع عن نفسها فقط بل ايضا للدفاع عن
ميثاق الامم المتحده ومبادئه